[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم النهارده معي ضيف
مميز جدا هو معالي السفير رفعه الانصاري
ليس فقط لانه يعني سفير مصري لديه خبرات
متراكمه في مجالات المتعدده ولكن تحديدا
لان لديهم مخزن اسرار في عالم الاستخبارات
بصفه عامه وخصوصا الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه
سفير رفعت الانصاري لديه خبره تقترب من
حوالي 45 سنه في متابعه الشان الاسرائيلي
بصفه عامه والشان الامني والاستخباراتي
بصفه خاصه هذه الخبرات بدات منذ عام 1981
لما كان واحد من سته الدبلوماسيين مصريين
فقط ذهبوا الى اسرائيل للخدمه هناك لخدمه
الخارجيه المصريه بعد التطبيع مباشره لكن
خلال اقل من تسع شهور ونص او عشر شهور قام
فيها بصولات وجولات ضد الموساد الاسرائيلي
اخرج يعني في عتمه الليل بعد ثلاث محاولات
اغتيال من الاجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه ضد
السفير رفعت الانصاري السفيره رفعت
الانصاري علشان نختصر الكلام يعني
الحقيقه لديه الكثير ليقوله وممكن لما اذا
سمح وقت معالي السفير يعني نشير في حلقات
اخرى الى مغامراته الكثير في اسرائيل
ومتابعه الشان الاسرائيلي مساء الخير مساء
الخير معالي السفير مساء الخير استاذ سيد
يعني الحديث عن مغامرات حضرتك وصورتك
وجوالاتك عاوزه حلقات مش حلقه واحده الله
يحفظك هي طويله الحقيقه ومتشعبه
هو يعني ده مغري ان احنا نبدا بها ولكن
احنا النهارده الحقيقه عندنا موضوع
استاذنك نبدا به ثم نعرك الى اذا سمح وقت
حضرتك عن
تجاربك الطويله في عالم الاستخبارات
والجاسوسيه
ايه سؤال بيلح علي من عدد كبير من
الاصدقاء والمتابعين
والسؤال ده
بيتعلق باختصار كيف تمكنت ايران
من تطوير قدراته النوويه الى ان وصلت
تقريبا الى العتبه يعني قادره الى تحويل
برنامجها السلمي حتى الان الى سلاح نووي
في اي وقت ان ارادت في غفله من الزمن يعني
في غفله من اجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه
واجهزه الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه اللي كانت
بتطارد كل دول المنطقه الراغبه واللي
عندها طموح في تطوير سلاح نووي
اجهدت المحاولات العراقيه اجهرت المحاولات
السوريه واجهضت محاولات اخرى سرا لدول
اخرى لماذا فشلت في اجهاد القدرات النوويه
الايرانيه
باختصار عشان انا مش عاوز وقتك وقت
الجمهور في الاول ايران كانت مرحب بها
عشان تاخد برنامج نووي في عهد الشاه بل
بالعكس
الشركات الامريكيه والاوروبيه كانت تتصارع
عليها عشان تديها هذا البرنامج وعلى الرغم
من البرنامج كان له صفه السلميه الا انك
كان الهدف منه معروف انه سيكون عسكري
العلاقات ما بين اسرائيل وايران كانت على
خير ما يرام كان هناك يعني اسرائيل عملت
اتفاق مع
التي ان اس اس اللي هو
ناشونال سيرفس اللي هي المخابرات التركيه
والسباك اللي هو المخابرات الايرانيه في
54 و55 وكنت لجنه اسمها ترايدن وهي اللجنه
الثلاثيه وكانت تعاون المخابرات على اشده
كانت ساعتها ايران بتساعد اسرائيل في انها
تستخرج اليهود العراقيين والسوريين في
الخمسينيات من داخل العراق وسوريا ولبنان
وخلافه من خلال الاكراد اكراد ايران
واكراد العراق وكانت بتسمح لهم بحاجه زي
كده في نفس الوقت كانت اسرائيل
بتساعد ايران منها بتجيب لها كل المعلومات
المخابراتيه
السوفييتيه عن ايران وده كان بيتم من خلال
المهاجرين السوفيات اللي بيرجعوا على
اسرائيل
65% من الاحتياجات البترونيه الاسرائيليه
كانت ايران بتكفيها اذا الموضوع كان هايل
وعلى فكره مثلا احكي لك على قصه لطيفه
لوقتنا هيسمع 77 كان في جنرال اسمه توفنال
كان ايراني كان في زياره الى اسرائيل
بنحاس ايامها كان نائب وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي اتفقوا على انهم كانوا لسه
عاملين الصواريخ الجديده اسمها جيركو اللي
بيسموها اريحا انه ياخذ صفقه فحتى بنحاس
قال للجنرال على فكره دي ممكن تحمل قنابل
ذريه لو انت عاوز فيما بعد واتفقوا ومضوا
التعاقد وكان من المفترض ان ان ايران
تستلم هذه الصواريخ في اول عام
حدثت الثوره وتنفست اسرائيل السعداء انها
مدوش هذه الصواريخ لايران بس قامت الثوره
قامت الثوره التسعه وسبعين اللي عاوز
اقوله ان بعد كده اول ما دخلت ايران حربها
مع العراق انت عارف هو دايما عندهم حاجه
اسمها برفرال اللي هو بيبقى عدو عدوي
صديقي وانه بيلف لها من ورا فكان اسرائيل
خدت القرار بانها تساعد ايران في حرب ضد
العراق وبالمناسبه هم قبل كده برده كان
الاثنين بيتعاونوا ايران واسرائيل سعه في
عهد الشام كانوا بيتعاونوا على
تدعيم الاكراد
للقلقله النظام واستقرار العراقي
ده هم كان عندهم مثل هذه الخطوات هل تاتي
بس ان انا اتحرك اقل بالنص دقيقه كل اللي
حضرتك قلته بتتكلم على قوه العلاقات
الايرانيه الاسرائيليه قبل عام 1979 دي
مرحله وفي 82 ل 83 ل 85 كانت مرحله اخرى
كانت العلاقات سريه وتزويد ايران بالسلاح
بمباركه امريكيه من جانب اسرائيل كان بيتم
والايرانيين كانوا بيقابلوا عملاء
المسادات اصحاب الشركات التصنيع الحربي في
اوروبا وكانت الامور ماشيه كنترا ايران
كونترا وايران اللي كانوا بيسموها هذه
الفضيحه الامريكيه كان الاساس فيها هم
عملاء مساد واصحاب شركات تصنيع سلاح
اسرائيل انما تم التغطيه والتعتيم على ذلك
وشالت امريكا
المسؤوليه بالكامل فيما يتعلق بتسريب
السلاح الى ايران اذا هنا لغايه هنا مرحله
انما توقفت هذه الامور
عاوزين نقول طب هتقول لي ازاي ايران بدات
الغريبه انه اول ملخومين جه قال لهم
الطاقه النوويه من عمل الشيطان انا مش
عاوز اسمع عنه حاجه وبالتالي ادى تعليماته
اوامره بتفكيك البرنامج النووي الايراني
الوليد في ذلك الوقت اللي هو كان من عهد
فضل هذا الامر ماشي من 79 الى 85 في 85
صدام حسين بدا يستخدم الاسلحه الكيماويه
وفاه الخميني كانت في اوائل 89 عندما جاء
خامن ايه اخد على عاتقه ان هو
لابد من ان احنا ننمي قدرتنا في اسلحه
الكيماويه اسلحه البيولوجيه والاسلحه
البرنامج عسكري النووي
ابو القنبله او ابو البرنامج النووي
الايراني هو رفض جاني وكان ساعتها رئيس
جمهوريه
اي برنامج نووي له ثلاث مكونات
المكون الاول هو العلماء فكيف يصل بمستوى
العلماء
في الحته دي راسا جاني بعد ما العلماء
هربوا من ساعه من ساعه الخميني
استجداهم وعمل اعلان رسمي في الصحف
الايرانيه بيعلن فيه عن مؤتمر لجذب وجلب
العلماء الايرانيين الهاربين في الخارج مع
الاعفاء الكامل من اي حاجات تجرمهم
واستكداهم ان انتم لابد ان تاتوا للبلد
الامه علشان تساعدوها حصل هذا المؤتمر جه
في عدد من العلماء الايرانيين مره اخرى
اخذوا القرار بانهم لابد من انشاء الكوادر
العلميه النوويه
بدا في الاول يبعت باعثات لامريكا
والانجلترا والاوروبا انما الاحظ ان
المخابرات الامريكيه والاوروبيه كان
عينيهم على الطلبه اللي هناك فحب يبعد عن
الموضوع ده فسحب هذه البسات وزود عليها
وبعد ابتدى يبعت فين الصين
وفي باكستان
وبدا في عمل اللي بيقولوا عليه نواه
الكوادر العلماء الايرانيين من هذه
البعثه اذا هو عمل بدا في تكوين وعمل
بالفعل ونجح خلال خمس ست سنين العنصر
البشري المكون الاخر لاي برنامج نووي هو
تكنولوجيا النوويه تكنولوجيا السواء بقى
كانت معامل وتخصيب ومفاعلات وخلافه لابد
ان يلجا الى دوله لديها هذه التكنولوجيا
فلجا في البدايه الى الاتحاد السوفيتي
والى الصين والى باكستان ايضا فيما بعد
لجا الى
كوريا الشماليه انما
الفتره دهيت لغايه بدايه التسعينيات
كان الكل يعني مش بصيص له هو كان تحت
الرادار
منذ بدايه التسعينيات من 91 بعد ما حصل
الغزو العراقي للكويت
والعراق كان اوريدي تم تدمير المفاعل
بتاعها في سنه 81
اصبحت كل الاعين والتركيز بتاع اجهزه
المخابرات الامريكيه والاوروبيه
والاسرائيليه هل يوجد برنامج نووي جديد في
العراق هل يوجد اسلحه دمار شامل في العراق
كان هذا هو التركيز واغفله ايران لان هم
ما كانوش حاسين بها اما جم في المكون
الثاني دوت بالفعل راسا جاني عمل زيارات
دوله للاتحاد السوفيتي وللصين وبدا في جلب
كميه كبيره جدا من التعاقدات كان بو شهر
مثلا مثل بسيط كان محطه نوويه بتتضمن
مفاعل نووي كان بها الف مهندس وفني روسي
وكانوا هم اللي بيقيموا ويشيدوا المباني
والخلافه
بدات الصين بنفس الحكايه وباكستان نفس
الشيء وابتدوا
الايرانيين نفسهم يكتسبوا الخبرات
المتراكمه ان هو كان مش بياخد حاجه لسه
بيبتدي بها ده واخد خبره متراكمه جايه له
وهو بيزود عليها
المكون الثالث هو المواد والمهمات
النوويه كيف تحصل ايران على مواد ومهمات
نوويه وبعد ما دخلت في بدايه الالفينات
واصبح عليها حظر
وبدات بعض العقوبات على ايران منذ بدايه
2022 لما اعلنت بداوا ياخدوا النموذج
الاسرائيلي فهو بيروح باعت باعثات
لطرق الابواب في الدول الاوروبيه وهذه
البئسات شكلهم اصلا رجال اعمال ولكن هم في
الحقيقه رجال المخابرات ايرانيين
اخرج عدد من رجال المخابرات الايرانيه
واستقروا في اوروبا واقاموا بالفعل شركات
الشركات ديت ابتدت تبقى على اتصال
بالشركات بتاعه الايرانيين او اللي من
اصول ايرانيه وبيقولوا لهم احنا علينا حظر
احنا يعني طالبين حاجات هي كلها يعني
استخدامها مواد لها استخدامات مزدوجه سلمي
ويقول له يعني ان ظائر المشعه عندنا عشان
علاج السرطان عشان الاطفال عشان خاطر
ابحاث الزراعه لان احنا محتاجين علشان
الصناعه عشان كل الكلام ده وبداوا بالفعل
يستقطبوا عدد من الشركات والشركات ديت
ابتدت هي الواجهه هو صحيح اصله ايراني
ولكنه شركه الماني فاواجهه المانيه في
داخل اوروبا شركه بريطاني شركه اسباني
شركه ايطالي وهكذا انما هو كان بدا يحصل
على المواد والمهمات ده بدا في سرقات
بالضبط نفس الاسلوب الاسرائيلي ساعه ما جه
يشيد البرنامج بتاعه بس الاسرائيلين كانوا
فاجرين شويه يعني كانوا بيسرقوا من امريكا
وهي الحليف الاستراتيجي الاول ودي لها قصص
وحكايات يعني وحلقات طويله انما دول كانوا
بيسرقوا من اوروبا من تركيا من من سويسرا
حاجات كده يعني فبدات اسراء وتكنولوجيا
النوويه مش بس تكنولوجيا هو بيسرق مواد
ومهمات
بيسمع
الاستيل الصفائح الحديديه الصلب اللي
بيتعمل منها اجهزه الطرد المركزي
الكمبيوترز اللي هي السوبر كمبيوترز اللي
كانت محظوره عليه بيخش لها في
صفقات من تحت الترابيزه من تحت الرادار
فبدا عمل الكلام ده الكل كان غفله وبدا
يستفيق من 2003
والغريبه ان بدايه الاستفاقه هنا كانت من
حاجه واحده لما معمر القذافي في ديسمبر
2003 اعلن اتفاقه مع الولايات المتحده على
ان هو يسلم برنامج النووي المسابقه لايه
ده هو في برنامج نووي في ليبيا ده احنا
قاعدين ناينين على وداننا مش حاسين طب اذا
كان ده بيسلم برنامج نووي هو هو جابه منين
طب ابتدوا يتتبعوا لا ده عبد القدير خان
عبد القدير خان جه زار فين اللي هو العالم
الباكستاني ابو القنبله الذريه
الباكستانيه وادعي له حلقه كامله ازاي
تحول من من طالب في هولندا الى عالم
وبالمناسبه عبد القدير خان هو اول من قام
بعمل اللي بيقولوا عليه السوق السوداء
للمواد المهمات النوويه والذريه والمناسبه
هو كان مكتبه في دبي وعمل شبكه شبكه مصر
طب ده ابتدى يزور يزور فين زار مصر وزاره
السعوديه لا دول تبع فيه ماشيين في فلك
الولايات المتحده وما فيش حاجه
جرح حتتين زار ايران وزار سوريا
فكانت تركيز بتاعهم بدا على ايران
ثم ابتدا يقول طب وصلوا لفين البرنامج عمل
ايه فبدا يستفيق شوف الايرانيين شغالين من
تحت الرادار من تحت الترابيزه من 86 الى
والمساد مغيب والاجهزه المخابرات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه مغيبه فاذا كنا
بنتكلم هنا لا الواحد يرفع القبعه للنظام
الايراني بغض النظر عن حسناته وسيئاته ان
هو استطاع ان يحافظ على السريه الكامله
علشان خاطر يصل بهذا الموضوع الى
مرحله متقدمه فيما يتعلق
بالبرنامج النووي الايراني سواء هم
بيقولوا هو سلمي وسوائل بيقول وهو عسكري
في جميع الاحوال الخط الفاصل ما بينهم هو
شعره معاويه
خط بسيط لانه يقدر ينتقل مدام وصل الى هذه
القدرات من المدنيه العسكريه بس معنى كلام
حضرتك او ملخص كلام حضرتك انه من وقت
المبكر تحت ضغط هو انه كان عندهم خبرات
متراكمه خلال فتره الشاه وده ما كانش يعني
محل اعتراض الاسرائيليين بسبب التحالف
الاستراتيجي ما بين ايران واسرائيل ومعاهم
كمان يعني علاقات طيبه مع تركيا ده قبل 79
صحيح حضرتك بتقول انه العلاقات
تاثرت بعد 79 لكنها كانت ايضا موجوده
لاسباب يطول شرحها ومن خلال ايران كونترا
مزبوط مش عاوز اسال حضرتك ليه استمر
التعاون رغم التناقضات الجوهريه بينهما
بعد 79 ممكن يكون يهم اسرائيل انها تضعف
وتهزم العراق بغض النظر عن من هو ضد
العراق حتى ولو كان الشيطان هو كان في
وجهه نظر يعني لدى اسرائيل وارجو تصلح لي
وحتى اعبر عنها علنا شخصيه
يهوديه مهمه في امريكا
لما قال انه الامريكان والاسرائيليين كانت
سياستهم تجاه ايران والعراق
ادعم المهزوم حتى
يبدا في الانتصار ثم اعكس التحالفات
والهدف تخليص على القوتين ده لصالح امريكا
ولصالح الاسرائيل اسرائيل لم تدعم العراق
في اي يوم من الايام فادعم المهزوم وكان
المهزوم لعده سنوات كان ايران فهو ظل يدعم
المهزوم ايران من 82 الى 35 لكايه في
العراق طبعا لان هو يهمه اكتر مش يهمه ان
العراق يبقى فايز او لا عاوز العراق يدمر
كان يهمه حتى ولو كان الامريكان بيدعموا
العراق بعض الشيء ليقف على على قدميه لا
هو كان يهمه دائما ان الايرانيين هم اللي
يخلصوا حاجه زي كده بس ده معنى كلام حضرتك
ان الموقف الاسرائيلي ما كانش مدفوع باي
تحيزات تجاه ايران ولكن فقط لضرب او يعني
اضعاف الجانب العراقي لهزيمه القدرات
العراقيه العسكريه لان دي دايما كانت عنده
بتعمل له صداع لانها موجوده
ويخشى في يوم من الايام ان يتم استخدامها
ضده فيما ان الامريكان كانوا مشغولين
بتوازن الاقليمي بين القوى اذا الذي يكون
في توازن للعراق يضعف جدا فتقوى ايران جدا
ولا العكس هو كان في شق واحد من
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه وليست في الشكرين
الشق هو اضعاف العراق اللي هو اسرائيل
كانت في شق واحد اللي هو اضعاف العراق
ودعم الايرانيين
بالسلاح وبالمعلومات جميل جدا
الجانب التاني اللي حضرتك قلته انه هم
نجحوا في
امتلاك كل ادوات او تطوير القدرات النوويه
عبر وسائل مختلفه تشابهت مع الوسائل
الاسرائيليه في الاستعانه بخبرات اجنبيه
في
تقويه الامكانات المحليه يعني الاستعانه
بالقدرات المحليه في سرقات واسعه للمواد
والاسرار التكنولوجيه علشان يناموا
برنامجهم برنامجهم وان حضرتك بتؤكد ان ده
كان في غفله عن الامريكان والاسرائيليين
اللي ما ادراكوش ان كان في برنامج
والاوروبيين كان في غفله من الزمن ومن هنا
برضو ابتدي اقول لك انه بدايه من 2001 كده
من 2000 ل 2021 بدات اسرائيل
تستشف وتشم ريحه حاجه قدرات موجوده هي ما
كانش عندها فكره
بدات في الاول
زودت عناصر اللي كانوا موجودين في المناطق
الكرديه اللي في العراق
خلي بالك المعارضه للنظام اه طبعا
خلي بالك انه
الجاليه اللي من اصول ايرانيه في اسرائيل
جاليه قويه للغايه وانا شفتهم بعيني
وتعاملت معاهم
اما اما بيجي واحد راجل اعمال عنده حاجه
اسمها البيت الابيض يعزمني فيه على الدعوه
على العشاء وده يمكن موجود في كتابي انا
كنت قلته
اما ببص على البذخ اللي موجود فيه بيعيش
فيه الايرانيين الاسرائيليين من اصول
ايرانيه يعني اليهود الايرانيين اليهود
الاسرائيليين من اصول ايرانيه
بدخ وقوه نفوذ يعني جه في وقت من الاوقات
مفاز اللي هو وزير الدفاع كان ايراني
الاصل رئيس الاركان كان ايراني الاصل عدد
مهم جدا من قيادات الاتنين المؤسسه
العسكريه وجيش الدفاع الاسرائيلي والمساد
والشين بيه ايرانيين بتقول كده بتدلل على
ايه على قوه النفوس الايراني في اسرائيل
ولا قدره اسرائيل على اختراق ايران ده
بيساعد الاسرائيليين على اخت لانه اما
بيجي بعد كده يعني مثلا هم عندهم فرقه
كونوها اسمها كاتسا الكاتسا دي كانت عباره
عن
عملاء اسرائيليين سواء كانوا من المخابرات
الحربيه او من الموساد او من
هؤلاء ايراني
المنشا
والشكل واللغه يعني جه ما بقالوش كم سنه
هذه المجموعه لما يبتدي يبعتها ويدخلها
تاني ايران
اللي هو يعني
هويات كلها مضروبه لكنها ايرانيه حقيقيه
وهو عنده
هوياته القديمه وخلافه ويخش ويعيش بهويه
جديده ويبتدي هو عارف المجتمع سابه من
اربع خمس سنين لما رجع له تاني هو مثلا
كان عايش في اهواز رجعوه في اصفهان حاجه
كانه جاي من طاهره بيبتدي يعيش
فاكر رافت الهجان اما ابتدى يعمل الشبكه
بتاعته هؤلاء كانوا بيعملوا شبكاتهم
داخل المجتمع الايراني طب هل ممكن استاذ
حركه ان النقطه اختراق الاسرائيليين لاحقا
لايران نخليها الحلقه اخرى نور انا بس
عاوز اقول لك ده كله كان لسه من بره ما
كانوش لسه عملوا استراتيجيه ولكن نقطه
المهمه انه في اماكن حول ايران بداوا
يقيموا منصات تنصت
وتجسس في اذربيجان في المناطق الكرديه
العراقيه
الايرانيه في قناه الكرديه التركيه فاصبح
عنده ناس جوه
واجهزه التجسس
من هنا بقى هتبتدي استراتيجيه اما وان
الايراني الاسرائيليين بداوا
يتنبهوا الاحتمال وجود برنامج نووي سر
لايران بعد كلام معمر القذافي وفق كلام
حضرتك او بعد اكتشاف برنامج نووي سر هم
برضو كانوا غافلين عنه
وبعد زي ما حضرتك بتقول ابتدا ينشروا
وسائل التنصت وربما كمان اختراق
للايرانيين باستخدام الاسرائيليين من اصل
ايراني هو السؤال اللي بيطرح نفسه جدا
لماذا لم يسعل اسرائيليون او لم يتمكن
الاسرائيليون من اجهاض البرنامج النووي
الايراني في 2002 وثلاثه واربعه وكان لسه
البرنامج في بدايته كما فعلوا مع السوريين
والعراقيين مين قال لك انه انه هم ما
كانوش قابقه قوسين او ادنى ان هم يوجهوا
الضربه كامله في 2005 اقول لك على كل
تفاصيلها
في 2005 كانوا
بيستعدوا لتوجيه ضربه على غرار بالعراق
كانوا بيستعدوا لتوجيه ضربات ما هو اصل
هنا في حاجه واحده
ايران تعلمت الدرس
من العراق اولا وفيما بعد بعد ما السوري
اتضرب انها ما تحطش البيض كله في سله
واحده مش موقع واحد عشان كده فوق الارض
العمليه مختلفه عن الاتنين وبالتالي فشلت
اسرائيل في تنفيذ طموحاتها في تصفيه
البرنامج النووي العراقي الايراني
عندما لم تقدم على الخطوه اللي كانت غابه
قوسين او ادنى بقى لها استراتيجيه اخرى
هسال حضرتك على الاستراتيجيه الاخرى لكن
معنى ذلك ان هي كانت بتسعى لتوجيه ضربه
مماثله لما فعلته في العراق في 81 ولما
فعلته في سوريا في 2007 لكن وجدت صعوبه في
صعوبات عده منها ان البرنامج النووي زي ما
حضرتك قلت استفادوا من بالك البرنامج
النووي الان يوجد حوالي 21 موقع نووي في
ايران موزعه مكرره وموزعه في ذلك الوقت
كانت هناك سته مواقع فقط في 2005 مارس
2005 فعشان كده اسرائيل
تخيلوا ان هم قادرين انهم يضربوا السته
مواقع وزي ما بقول لك كان لها اعدادات
معينه ممكن احكيها لك يعني في مارس 2005
وفضلت هذه الاعدادات
اللي بيقولوا عليها فول اليرت يعني في تحت
استعداد بانذار للبدء لمده ثمانيه اشهر
وبعدين تخزق قرار السياسي هل في اجابه
قصيره ليه تاخذ قرار سياسي بعدم اجهاض
البرنامج النووي الايراني
المسات تدخل وقال انه الخطوره من الضربات
الجويه ستكون اكثر بكثير من مما سيمكننا
من تحقيقه يعني الخسائر اكثر من الفوائد
وفي نفس الوقت المساد كان بدا من 2002 او
المماير ده جنجي بدا في استراتيجيه بدت
انها ناجحه
يعني كانت تقديرات السلطات الاسرائيليه ان
احنا سوف نحقق الهدف ولكن بوسائل اخرى هل
تاذن لي طبعا انا عاوز يعني معلومه صحه لي
ثم تاذلي بطلب يعني انا عندي معلومه انه
كان الامريكان عندهم تحفظ من اجراء
اسرائيل عمليه عسكريه مكشوفه لان هم كانوا
غارقين في مستنقع العراق بدلا من 2003
وبالتالي اخر ما كان يتمناه الامريكان ان
يبداوا حربا اخرى على جبهه جديده مع
الايرانيين هل المعلومه منطقيه ولا مش
مقبوله
فيما بعد اصبحت منطقيه ولكن بوش اتخذ قرار
بضرب ايران في ديسمبر 2007 وقال انا
عاوزها في بحد اقصى يناير 2008
ولم تتم لم تتم لان تدخل والسي اي اي
تدخلت وقالت له هذه التقديرات ادي
التقديراتنا ايضا لن تكون ضربه ناجحه ودي
برضو قصه تانيه بس القسم المشترك لان كده
يعني القسم المشترك تقديرات البنتاجون
الموساد انه البرنامج
يعني اكبر بكثير من ان يتم تصفيته بعمليه
صغيره ليس فقط ده لها عناصر اخرى ممكن
نتكلم فيها طيب نستاذن حضرتك ان احنا
نتكلم على استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده
واستراتيجيه اسرائيل اللي فشلت في اجهاض
البرنامج النووي الايراني بعمليه عسكريه
واحده وحاسمه
ونسال حضرتك ما هي الاستراتيجيات اللي
سعوا
الاتباعها وتبنيها الاجهاض البرنامج او
على الاقل تعطيله في حلقه اخرى هل تاذن
لنا
اوكي حاضر بالمناسبه ليه ما تفكرش تعمل
قناه مع السفير وتتحدث فيها عن تجربتك
العريضه يعني في عالم الاستخبارات والله
انا ليا عدد من الاصدقاء فعلا
زي ما بنقول ايه بيلحوا عليا في انا ليس
لدي خبره يوتيوب ولكن الفكره بدات يعني
تروق لي فانا بدرسها واذا كان كده ربما
اعمل فعلا قناتي اللي هتبقى عن الشان
الاسرائيلي فقط لا غير مش هتطرق لاي
موضوعات اخرى انما دي انا يعني بحترم هذا
التخصص وهذا هو تخصصي من 45 سنه وبالتالي
ستكون عن اسرائيل
المؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه الاجهزه
الامنيه الاجهزه المخابراتيه بكافه
عملياتها هذا هو
الموضوع الاساسي اذا كنت حاعمل
قناه وربما بقى مشاهدينك هم اللي يقولوا
اه اعمل قناه ولا لا انا هعتمد عليهم وانا
اكون اول المشتركين متشكره شكرا جزيلا
معلش شكرا سيدي